[Musique]
si vous demandez à n'importe qui autour
de vous si tu sais ce qu'est l'art il
est très peu probable qu'il vous réponde
non l'art fait partie de nos vies et nul
besoin d'être spécialiste en la matière
pour savoir intuitivement ce qu'on
désigne à travers ce mot pourtant si
vous demandez à cette même personne de
vous expliquer ce qu'est l'art ou d'en
donner une définition alors les choses
vont commencer à se compliquer pour elle
l'art est une notion difficile à définir
est d'ailleurs tout le monde n'a pas
forcément la même conception entre celui
qui répondra collard c'est ce qu'on
trouve dans les musées ou celui qui
verra en lui un moyen d'accéder au divin
en passant par ceux qui font de l'art un
espace de création ou encore le lieu
d'expression de la sensibilité ou de
l'inspiration de l'artiste on voit bien
à quel point il est compliqué de
s'entendre sur une définition commune
est unanime de ce qu'est l'art après
tout chacune de ces définitions contient
peut-être une partie de la vérité ou
bien l'art est il tout simplement ce que
chacun voudra y voir l'art comme
subjectivité
[Musique]
mais ne peut-on pas tenter d'y voir plus
clair un rapide examen de l'étymologie
de ce mot peut nous y aider
le mot art vient du latin ars qui
signifie habileté technique savoir faire
par ailleurs en grec arts se disait
techno ce qui semble se rapprocher du
sens que lui donne le mot latin l'art
serait donc d'abord la maîtrise
technique ce qui n'a rien de surprenant
car bien qu'on oublie parfois l'artiste
est d'abord celui qui maîtrise d'un
savoir faire technique pour être peintre
il faut en effet avoir appris à peindre
c'est à dire à manier un pinceau de même
que pour être musicien il faut d'abord
être capable de jouer convenablement
d'un instrument de musique c'est
pourrait-on dire la condition minimale
sans technique padar et sans
apprentissage c'est à dire sans travail
pas de maîtrise technique
remarquons au passage que le mot art
entendu comme savoir faire technique
renvoie aussi bien à la création de
l'artiste qu'à la fabrication de
l'artisan artiste et artisan aurait
ainsi un important point commun celui de
façonner la matière pour en extraire une
oeuvre ou un ouvrage n'oublions pas que
l'oeuvre c'est d'abord et avant tout le
produit de celui qui oeuvre
c'est à dire de l'ouvrier oeuvre en
latin se dit opéra
par ce simple rappel nous voyons déjà
que nous nous heurtons à une première
idée reçue celle qui fait de l'art le
lieu de la seule inspiration de
l'artiste alors que l'inspiration livrée
à elle même et quand bien même elle
serait très estimable ne saurait à elle
seule produire dollars l'inspiration se
trouve dans l'esprit alors que l'art
prolonge cette inspiration au delà de
l'esprit de l'artiste pour lui conférer
une matérialité une réalité sensible que
ce soit par l'organe de la vue de l'ouïe
voire du toucher comme par exemple dans
le cas de la sculpture
[Musique]
cela peut paraître évident à première
vue et pourtant dit de cette manière
cela nous permet de comprendre beaucoup
de choses ainsi l'arrêt liées au domaine
de la sensibilité
pas de la sensibilité au sens de
l'émotion bien qu'il nous faudra aborder
cette question par la suite mais au sens
de ce qui peut être reçue est perçue par
nos sens autrement dit par notre corps
en résumé si l'esprit et la provenance
de l'art le corps en est la destination
le passage de l'un à l'autre s'effectue
par l'opération de l'artiste le
processus de création
[Musique]
l'idée que l'art s'adresse
prioritairement à nos sens peut nous
aider à comprendre une autre opinion
assez répandu pour de bonnes ou de
mauvaises raisons nous verrons l'art
doit être beau cette définition de l'art
comme recherche de la beauté est l'une
des plus couramment admise y compris
inconsciemment et quand bien même elle
ferait l'objet à notre époque de
sérieuses contestation lorsque nous
écoutons une composition musicale ou une
chanson lorsque nous regardons une toile
peinte ou un monument architectural
c'est sa beauté que nous recherchons et
c'est elle qui nous amènera à juger
l'oeuvre en fonction du sentiment ou de
l'émotion qu'elle aura su produire en
nous
on dit souvent d'une oeuvre qu'on aime
qu'elle nous touche nous voulons dire
par laquelle nous émeut et déclenche ce
quelque chose à l'intérieur de nous qui
a à voir avec le sentiment du bourg
remarquer qu'il est tout à fait possible
d'éprouver un tel sentiment sans passer
par le biais de l'art par exemple en
contemplant un paysage naturel un
coucher de soleil ou encore en assistant
à un événement spécial qui produira en
nous un effet très proche une
déclaration d'amour une réconciliation
entre deux amis qui ne s'était plus
parlé depuis de longues années un acte
de charité de courage ou de pardon
peut-être y at-il quelque chose comme de
l'art dans les exemples que je viens de
citer et tous ceux qui auront vu passer
des images dans leur tête au moment où
je les évoquer auront peut-être le temps
de ressentir une émotion assez proche de
celle que cherche à faire naître
l'artiste à travers une oeuvre ce qui
montre bien que lorsqu'on parle de
beauté en art on ne parle pas de la
beauté au sens habituel et banal du
terme une voiture peut être belle sans
pour autant être considéré comme une
oeuvre d'art à part peut-être pour
certains amateurs un vase des rideaux un
téléphone portable pourrait aussi être
qualifiée de beaux mais sont ils pour
autant des oeuvres d'art
rien n'est moins sûr il ne faut donc pas
confondre beauté et joliesse bien que ce
mot pour le coup ne soit lui-même pas
très joli on dit d'une chose qu'elle est
jolie quand on la trouve agréable à
regarder ou à entendre ce qui est joli
procure une sensation agréable un
plaisir des sens mais ça ne va pas plus
loin la joliesse débouche sur ce que le
philosophe allemand emmanuel kant appelé
l'agrément l'agrément et en ce qui est
agréable à nos sens
la sensation n'est pas le sentiment la
sensation est dans quelque sorte la
couche superficielle du sentiment et une
grande partie des désaccords au sujet de
ce qui est beau et de ce qui ne l'est
pas provient du fait que nous confondons
souvent sans le vouloir sentiments et
sensations beauté et agrément
prenons un exemple qui devrait nous
éclairer si je dis que victoria est plus
belle que margot supposons j'exprime un
jugement de goût autrement dit j'aimais
une opinion personnelle qui ne fait que
traduire mes préférences en termes
d'agrément
selon que je préfère les blondes ou les
brunes les grandes où les petites les
yeux bleus ou les yeux marron quelqu'un
d'autre pourra très bien être de l'avis
contraire et trouvé que margot est plus
belle que victoria sans que cela ne
modifie mon jugement et sans que l'on
puisse dire que l'un d'eux nous a raison
et que l'autre à tort en réalité dans
cette situation nous ne faisons qu
exprimer une différence de goût quant à
l'agrément que suscite chez nous tel ou
tel personne or comme chacun sait des
goûts et des couleurs on ne discute pas
l'agrément est liée aux goûts personnels
de chacun et concerne exclusivement le
domaine des sens la beauté quant à elle
est indépendante du goût et concerne le
domaine de l'esprit elle est de l'ordre
du sublime et le sublime n'est pas une
affaire de subjectivité
quand bien même tout le monde n'y serait
pas aussi sensible
au xviiie siècle le philosophe
britannique jeremy bentham fonda
l'utilitarisme une doctrine qui fait du
plaisir le but ultime de l'existence
humaine
selon madame tous les plaisirs se valent
et quiconque jugerait que plonger ses
doigts dans un pot de confiture pour les
lécher goût du mans est un plaisir moins
noble que l'extase spirituel provoquée
par la lecture d'un poème est à ses yeux
dans l'erreur pourtant ne reconnaissons
nous panneaux même cette idée dans notre
vie de tous les jours
à savoir que certains plaisirs ont plus
de valeur que d'autres je peux avoir
beaucoup de plaisir à dormir par exemple
sans organiser ma vie autour de cette
seule activité comme je peux apprécier
grandement les plaisirs de la table sans
pour autant passer mes journées à manger
bien entendu ce qui nous donne du
plaisir nous est propre et ne saurait
être question de juger en bien ou en mal
les plaisirs de chacun cependant nous
savons faire la différence entre ses
diverses formes de plaisir et ce qu'on
appelle le bonheur qui est un état très
supérieur au seul plaisir des sens pour
revenir à notre propos initial nous
pourrions dire que le plaisir est au
bonheur ce que l'agrément est à la
beauté une sensation passagère et
subjective qui bien qu'agréable ne nous
donne pas la satisfaction et la
plénitude de l'autre dire que la beauté
n'est pas quelque chose de subjectif
mais au contraire quelque chose
d'objectif et d'universel c'est se
heurter de plein fouet à l'opinion
dominante pour laquelle le goût
personnel passe avant toute idée de
hiérarchie
nous répétons que c'est une erreur de
confondre beauté et agrément et que si
l'on peut affirmer que la beauté quelque
chose d'objectif et d'invariants c'est à
dire quelque chose qui dépasse nos
préférences esthétiques personnel c'est
qu'il ya une raison à cela c'est ce que
nous verrons dans la dernière partie de
cet épisode parmi les autres définition
que l'on donne à l'art il y en a une qui
a longtemps occupé le haut du pavé c'est
celle de l'art comme imitation de la
nature
une oeuvre d'art est belle si elle
reproduit fidèlement la réalité
autrement dit c'est elle est une bonne
copie de l'objet qu'elle cherche à
représenter une telle définition paraît
toutefois peu satisfaisante car si l'on
y réfléchit elle ne fait que dire
autrement ce que nous suggérions lorsque
nous parlions de l'art comme savoir
faire technique
je m'explique si la valeur d'une oeuvre
d'art dépend uniquement de son degré de
ressemblance avec ce qu'elle représente
c'est l'habileté de l'artiste a
travaillé sur les formes les couleurs
les perspectives les textures qui lui
permettra d'atteindre un tel degré de
réalisme et d'exactitude dans tous les
cas ce n'est pas tant la beauté de
l'oeuvre qui sera prise en compte que
les compétences techniques de son auteur
qui lui auront permis d'atteindre le
résultat le plus proche possible de
l'original en art il existe un courant
réaliste aussi bien en peinture qu'en
littérature le réalisme est née au
milieu du 19e siècle de la volonté de
certains artistes de décrire la réalité
telle qu'elle est et est telle qu'il la
voyait sans chercher à l'embellir ou à
l'idéaliser le but de l'art n'était plus
selon eux de sublimer le monde comme le
prétendaient les romantiques mais de le
restituer fidèlement à la manière d'un
journaliste méticuleux voire d'un
scientifique
quoi qu'on pense du réalisme il est
clair qu'on ne saurait limiter le champ
d'action de l'artiste à cette seule
approche qui en fait surtout à un
technicien au détriment d'autres
manières de représenter et de figurer le
monde l'art de reproduire le réel par
les formes laissons les mots ou les
couleurs étaient nommés par les grecs de
l'antiquité me mais si ce mot dans
lequel nous retrouvons la racine du
verbe me met très proche de celui
d'imiter contrairement au réalisme la mi
mai si sa tâche est moins à restituer
les apparences de la réalité que cette
réalité elle même dit à s'éloigner dans
certains cas des apparences perçue par
mon sens
le problème de la conception réaliste de
l'art c'est qu'elle ne fait pas la
distinction entre l'apparence du monde
qu'elle cherche à restituer et la
réalité de ce monde platon qui vécut à
athènes au vème siècle avant
jésus-christ et est très critique envers
les artistes qui se contentait d'imiter
l'apparence des objets matériels qui se
trouvait sous leurs yeux des objets qui
pour platon et sans trop entrer dans les
détails étaient déjà une forme dégradée
et corrompu parce que matérielle de la
réalité intelligible la seule réellement
existante à travers l'art il ne s'agit
donc pas seulement imiter ce que nous
percevons du monde mais de manière plus
subtile ce qui anime le monde sans que
nous le percevons par nos sens les
passions humaines sont ainsi
représentées et incarné dans les
tragédies dont le recours fréquent à
l'amplification et à l'exacerbation des
sentiments traduit davantage ce que sont
fondamentalement ses passions que la
manière dont elles se manifestent au
quotidien dans ce cas on dit de la mi
mai si ce qu'elle est non mimétique elle
s'éloigne de l'apparence du réel pour
mieux se rapprocher de son essence
profonde et invisible quitte à parfois
déconcerté mais le réel n'est-il pas
foncièrement déconcertant
[Musique]
où
cela nous amène à la dernière partie de
cet épisode
si vous avez suivi tout ce qui a été dit
jusqu'à présent il ne vous sera demandé
qu'un effort d'attention supplémentaire
pour tenir jusqu'au bout et si ce qui a
été dit ne vous semble pas très clair il
n'est évidemment pas interdit de
réécouter
[Musique]
pour platon la beauté est une propriété
de la vérité ou dit autrement la beauté
et la vérité ne sont qu'une seule et
même chose exprimée sous des formes
différentes c'est une idée qui peut
paraître assez étrange lorsque l'on
n'est pas habitué à cette manière de
penser pourtant on la retrouve dans
beaucoup d'autres domaines par exemple
en sciences lorsqu'un chercheur tient à
ce que la formule qu'il met au point
soit élégante sans que cela ne modifie
en rien son résultat ou encore en
politique où les idéaux prônés tient
davantage à la beauté d'une société
juste qu'à son caractère fonctionnel
platon d'ailleurs appelé sa cité idéale
l'acadie police la belle cité mais
revenons aux sujets la beauté en arts
serait l'équivalent de la vérité en
sciences ou de la bonté pour ce qui
concerne la vie morale beauté vérité et
bonté ne serait en fait qu'une seule et
même chose vu sous des angles différents
et exprimé dans des langages propres
elles ont pour source commune l'unité
que platon appelé le bien mais que
d'autres appelleraient dieu il ne faut
pas se focaliser ici sur la connotation
contemporaine de ces termes qui si on
les interprète correctement et selon l'
usage traditionnel désigner une seule et
même chose un mot permet de résumer ce
que le beau le vrai et le bon exprime
c'est l'harmonie or il se trouve qu'en
grec harmonie se disait cosmos le cosmos
c'est le nom donné à l'univers c'est à
dire au monde pris dans son sens le plus
large et qui suppose que ce même univers
obéit à des lois lesquels manifeste
l'ordre les lois qui régissent le cosmos
ne sont pas visibles à l'oeil nu c'est
pourquoi leurs découvertes nécessite le
recours à l'observation et à l'intellect
afin de les formuler pour beaucoup ce
sont les mathématiques qui régissent le
cosmos au point que certains comme
pythagore n'ont pas hésité à dire que
les nombres étaient le langage de dieu
entendez du principe créateur
mais alors me direz-vous quel rapport
avec l'art si l'harmonie est une
propriété du cosmos de l'univers la
beauté est le reflet de cette harmonie
sous une forme sensible remarqué à quel
point le mot harmonie est d'ailleurs
omniprésent dans l'art dans la musique
bien sûr mais aussi dans la peinture
avec l'harmonie des formes dans la
poésie avec l'harmonie des mots dans la
danse avec l'harmonie des mouvements et
c'est
l'harmonie semble incontournable et tout
le travail de l'artiste semble être
précisément de la restituer à travers
son oeuvre quand bien même celle-ci
s'affranchirait des apparences ainsi il
est possible de dire qu'une composition
musicale et juste lorsqu'elle produits
en nous un sentiment d'harmonie c'est à
dire lorsqu elle traduit fidèlement et
précisément le sentiment que le musicien
cherche à véhiculer même chose pour la
poésie où il arrive parfois que les
verts que nous lisons nous semble
totalement dénué de sens si nous les
prenons dans leur signification
littérale est explicite l'art n'est pas
le lieu de l'exquis site mais de
l'implicite il n'est pas le lieu du
superficiel et de l'apparent mais du
profond et du subtil l'art des finances
il s'adresse au coeur
nombreux sont les artistes et les
intellectuels qui ont tenté de donner
une définition objective de la beauté
quand bien même une telle entreprise
risquerait d'être mal accueillies dans
l'encyclopédie des lumières à l'article
beau diderot écrit que la beauté est le
résultat de la perception de rapport
la notion de rapport indique que la
beauté réside davantage dans la
disposition des éléments les uns par
rapport aux autres que dans ces éléments
eux mêmes vous pouvez faire l'expérience
par vous même choisissez une belle
chemise à pois un beau pantalon à
rayures une belle veste à carreaux et
voyez si le résultat est beau vous vous
rendrez alors compte que la beauté ne
résulte pas de la simple addition
d'éléments beau mais de l'harmonie
générale des éléments combinés
la beauté est une affaire de relation
nous pourrions dire de proportion pas
étonnant que léonard de vinci ou encore
jean sébastien bach et eu autant recours
à la géométrie du nombre d'or dans leur
oeuvre une présence discrète donc
efficace là encore des mathématiques
[Musique]
si vous admettez ce raisonnement alors
vous admettrez aussi cette définition de
l'harmonie si précieuse à la démarche
artistique la source invisible de la
beauté visible
au 19e siècle le philosophe allemand
hegel écrivait que l'art était la
cristallisation de l'absolu sous une
forme sensible
nous retrouvons ici l'idée que
l'ambition de l'art ne saurait en aucun
cas se réduire à la simple imitation des
apparences au contraire il est le réel
lui même s'incarnant dans une forme
sensible
maintenant beaucoup mieux pourquoi
certains artistes ont pu être qualifié
de prophète
il ne s'agissait pas de dire qu'ils
annonçaient dans leurs oeuvres le
devenir du monde et de l'humanité un
prophète est quelqu'un qui fait office
de transmetteurs entre le divin et le
monde des hommes c'est donc celui au
travers duquel dieu trouve l'occasion de
s'exprimer
la vocation de l'artiste semble
rejoindre celle du prophète à savoir
celle d'être le canal entre l'ordre
cosmique et la matérialité humaine
l'artiste n'est finalement qu'un
interprète un interprète si subtile si
transparent qu'il peut facilement passer
pour fou au point d'être considéré comme
tel par ses contemporains
ne dit on pas que les véritables
artistes sont généralement reconnus
après leur mort
véritable quart véridique véritable car
porteur d'une vérité une vérité qui ne
s'adresse pas à la raison mais au coeur
blaise pascal distinguer ceux qui
l'appelaient des vérités de raison et
des vérités de coeur les vérités de
raisons sont celles que cherche à
dévoiler les scientifiques qui s'adresse
d'abord à notre intellect les vérités de
coeur trouvent leur expression
privilégiée dans l'art et dans la
religion ces deux formes de vérité
vérité de raison et vérité de coeur sont
bien entendu incomparable une avec
l'autre et il semble que ce soit la
tâche du philosophe de les réconcilier
de les unifier n'oublions pas qu'on grec
vérité se disait aletheia qui signifie
retrait du voile le voile des apparences
or aletheia signifier également réalité
encore une fois le rôle de l'art semble
bien être de restituer le réel dans sa
vérité
cet épisode n'avait évidemment pas la
prétention de proposer un exposé six
thématiques sur l'art ni d'en épuiser le
sujet nous espérons seulement qu'il aura
apporté des éléments de réflexion à tous
ceux qui s'interrogent sur ce qui fonde
notre humanité et anime notre désir de
connaître le monde dont la culture au
delà de ces clivages demeure la plus
belle illustration
[Musique]
nous avons volontairement choisi de ne
pas aborder la définition de l'art comme
provocation puisqu'il semble qu'une
telle définition soit à la mode nous
nous contenterons de poser une simple
question qui nous servira de conclusion
si la mission de l'art et de provoquer
que doit-il provoquer des ricanements
des injures
des offenses ou bien at il un but plus
élevé celui de nous transporter au delà
de nous mêmes ce qui semble rejoindre le
but de l'existence elle même nous rendre
meilleurs
c'est à vous de juger
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]